I do I do so I I I have heard a change
of heart over one thing okay
um so uh after about three days three
days in Thailand by the way there wasn't
a single day in Thailand well I did not
have uh the most horrendously spicy food
when when the moment me and Sydney
stepped off the plane we were just like
just go to town just just go to town let
give us all of the spicy food that we
can't get in Japan
um and so by day three my [__] was no
Ryan dude I I'm I was struggling yeah I
needed I had like I would [__] like 10
times a day and it was done every time
yeah yeah but I also was like Mount
Saint Helen yeah yeah it was insane it
was so sore and so and so here are um at
my house sitting on my toilet and I I
was having I was having one of those
shits where it was like the sweats that
came with it you know that take your
shirt off yeah it was that and and I
remember just sitting down I and I
reached over for the bidet and it wasn't
there and I was just like if there's one
country that needs a bidet it's Thailand
why is it not here right now the spice
they use I'm shocked in their butthole
yeah people just getting used to it is
that is that that poops normal or is it
is everyone pooping like that or maybe
in Thailand the general consensus is
yeah poops are painful right yeah that's
the default I don't know I mean I don't
think I ever got used to it I just fight
for my life yeah you just get used to
like fine for your life we do have a
like a sort of like bidet kind of thing
in Thailand but that that didn't do it
yeah it literally it literally
I need
it you shouldn't sniper right to where
the I was trying to like fully shower my
ass cheeks
yeah exactly it was not gonna work yeah
they they had they had like a hose you
could shotgun your ass I needed a
Precision sniper right where the area
that was on [__] fire and it just
wasn't there so the first thing I did
was I'm like Mom can I buy a bidet for
this house please
I need it okay in Thailand
[Laughter]
yeah but like where else did you guys go
like what what areas did you guys so the
day after the wedding the day you didn't
join us we we obviously went to the the
big Marketplace which is which is super
cool I mean like we I don't think we
even explored like 10 of that place
because it's so massive yeah um but yeah
uh 25 for a pad time yeah yeah yeah oh
okay okay so we paid them we were like
all right well let's get out of here
before we get scanned more so we went to
um this uh the Xian Paragon I think yeah
the same Paragon which is like a kind of
a mall nearby
um did a bit of shopping there and then
yeah I guess just for the rest of the
night we were just there we went back to
that uh uh bar in The Hangover yeah oh
yeah because when I when I heard that
you guys were staying in leboa I was
like oh you you guys are staying in it's
one of the most famous hotels in Bangkok
specifically because that's the hotel
where they filmed the hangover too that
scene at the end where the helicopter
comes on the rooftop that's the bar that
is filmed at
um and I know this uh because I assume
everything there was horrendously
overpriced
specifically because this is where The
Hangover 2 took place dude we're looking
at the menu and Emily's like I think we
want to get this drink I'm like Emily
that's a hundred dollar drink she was
like I'm not gonna get that drink
the cheapest drinks they had were 40 USD
right yeah yeah we paid 40 bucks for a
gin and tonic I just wanted to see the
view you're like one drink we'll check
out the view we'll bounce because you're
on the like 65th floor overlooking the
whole city The View was amazing
for the viewers I mean at least it I
mean it was one of the strongest gin and
tonics I had so I guess you know it
wasn't worth it they were trying to
level it out but I'm like it's still 40
and I'm like yeah yeah I'll you know
I'll just take a couple of pictures up
here and then yeah you know but was was
it was the hotel worth it no I didn't
like that room was buggy as hell I don't
know dude like our hotel room it was
like if you want to take a shower yeah
it was just like every five seconds it
was a quick Time Event because you just
changed the temperature because it would
just scold you randomly you need to keep
changing it I was like what the [__]
yeah I didn't have that problem at all
the Wi-Fi was like ass which all right
you know is whatever but uh there was
like TVs missing uh what else uh they
like lost our bags at one point dude it
was like it was a nightmare good to know
and it was so expensive yeah because I
I've never stayed at that hotel before
because it is one of the most expensive
hotels in Bangkok because like like I
said because simply because of The
Hangover too simply because of the
marketing they got for that it's like
that prices rocketed it is a high price
for Thailand it's like 200 bucks a night
yeah which is you know I mean in the UK
they get you nothing yeah that doesn't
even get you an airport okay so I was
like oh okay I'll spend 200 bucks a
really nice room yeah I think it was
going to be like goated and it was it
was not very good okay they're they're
probably a lot better hotels that you
can get for a lot cheaper honestly the
first time yeah we stayed at this other
hotel that was close to God's house for
the wedding and that was like I think 40
or 50 a night and it was so good it was
so much better the most costly better
and like the bed was amazing the service
was super good and then we ordered room
service and the room service was so
cheap it was like it was like five bucks
for like all the memes yeah what the
[__] we thought I am I suck so we
ordered it it was so good yeah it was
really cool I ordered green curry that
cost like 180 bar yeah and I was like
what how does that make any sense how
are they making money okay that's okay
that's good to know because the hotel's
really good yeah yeah yeah yeah
um just just because yeah um I have
never stayed in the Burr I've always
like I've always been curious no because
it's the most expensive one but the
breakfast was good though yeah that's
about it yeah that's about it yeah I I
don't really think it's worth it to be
honest okay yeah next time you go we
like we go we'll get a different we'll
stay at that first hotel honestly that
that place
like I know some like pretty good hotels
um that are a bit less than liberal but
like even better than the other Hotel
okay I recommended for you yeah I think
I think three days is a pretty good
amount though I felt like I kind of had
especially the food yeah I think my
stomach was like begging me to stop yeah
so I think three days was perfect how
does anyone stay in shape in Thailand
like I would I would be fat as [__] if I
lived in Thailand for like more than a
month dude it's all like you get all the
mango smoothies yeah and goes everywhere
there's coconuts everywhere I had so
much coconut ice cream dude yeah so good
the fresh coconut ice cream is so good
it's so good that diet is like Dom
didn't even know that it was like
coconut ice cream yeah
you know because it's just white ice
cream right and I'm like oh what flavor
is that and he's like I think it's
vanilla yeah I'm like what do you mean
you think it's vanilla I had a scoop and
I'm like this is clearly coconut and
he's like he hates Coke
he hates coconut with a passion I was
like Don this is coconut and he's like
yeah I didn't really like it I'm like
you ate the whole thing though you're
such a [__] liar how does your brain
off yeah I'm glad you enjoyed the Thai
sausage though that was so good as the
biggest sausage connoisseur [__] love
sausages yeah because then he's JoJo fan
yeah and I mean obviously if you ever
had Thai sausage
um it doesn't taste like a normal
sausage it's very spicy very flavorful
as as it is yeah I I don't know like I
feel like it wasn't oh man that's the
word it doesn't have that like super
nice bite to it that some sausages have
yeah but the flavors of the spices in it
were insane yeah kind of made me
seeing you enjoy that sausage uh yes and
kind of like being back in time I kind
of made me realize why Thai Cuisine is
the way it is just because compared to
you know more developed countries the
meat quality isn't the best yeah right
but we kind of like make up for that by
just making the flavors so so strong for
sure uh that's it's kind of almost the
opposite of Japanese Cuisine Japanese
Cuisine is all about letting the letting
the meat quality letting the quality of
the ingredients kind of like
do that one yeah letting natural flavors
take over Thai is more likely how many
[__] spices can we put in this get it
give me give me more spices
oh so good yeah I heard uh online before
you go to town you weren't supposed to
drink the tap water or avoid ice yeah it
was impossible to avoid ice ice was in
everything they put ice in everything so
it's this is more of like in the rural
areas okay uh it's also on the food
stalls in in the food stores if you if
you buy stuff on the food and they have
a bucket full of rice or something
that's probably from tap water but if
you're in a mall or in the hotel or you
know the icicle at my wedding that's
that's ice that we've specifically
bought that's been like purified I mean
I thought I was getting a hit for sure
with the amount of mango and watermelon
smoothies I was drinking but I was good
this time I pulled the good RNG yeah
every time we'd go to a food food store
and one of these guys would ask me uh
God is this is this safe and I'm like
gonna be honest you're playing RNG uh
it's like but it's banging food It's
banging food but you're about to pull
the food poisoning gotcha hopefully you
get something good yeah exactly exactly
yeah but yeah glad you guys enjoyed the
food tour really good yeah Thai food is
as good as I thought it was going to be
yeah which is good to know